quatre commissions scalable oui je veut
les préserver parce que c'est un endroit
de proximité pour les parents me le dit
partout au québec parce qu'ils peuvent
parler à leurs commissaires scolaires et
oui faudrait qu'ils votent plus les gens
pour les élections scolaires en passant
cas il ya un enjeu
quand il ya une école menacée de
fermeture les gens vont voter pour leurs
commissaires scolaires particulièrement
dans nos régions et c'est une erreur de
penser sur le go que ce ne sont pas des
actions importantes pour les régions
c'est pas du lobbying fait les citoyens
qui en ont besoin
maintenant oui réduire la bureaucratie
ministère directions régionales plus
d'argent dans les écoles pour l'aide aux
devoirs
on leur offre sage de l'anglais et la
réussite de même ce quia vous visez le
mauvais endroit vous avez pas fait vos
devoirs je vous donne les chiffres là il
ya à peu près 1000 personnes au
ministère d'éducation
à peu près 600 personnes dans les
directions régionales de ça et il y en a
quatre mille cinq cents dans les
commissions scolaires c'est nokia c'est
le canal + mais vous vous êtes pas
capables de résister au lobby des
commissaires d'école qui sont plaints
dans vos congrès libéral
vous n'avez pas de démolir cette
structure qui fait son temps écoutez 7,9
pour cent de parts réservation est ce
que vous trouvez que c'est de la
démocratie forces du créateur de sapec
aux structures si vous étiez de la santé